over the weekend mark german dropped a
huge leak bomb on us concerning apple's
entire 2022 mac lineup including some
very controversial details like how face
id will finally make its way to the mac
as well as some disappointing details
concerning which max will not be getting
the incredible promotion 120 hertz
feature so with this last report from
mark i am happy to say that we finally
have the missing piece of the puzzle
that can put a lot of completely
baseless rumors to rest and confirm when
each mac should be coming later this
year so without further ado let's jump
right into it now the first thing i want
to talk about is the redesign m2 macbook
air which a lot of people believe was
coming this spring at apple's march
event which actually has a likelihood of
taking place just one month from now on
march 8th but before i get into why the
idea of the m2air coming in just one
month has officially been confirmed to
be wrong i want to talk about what i
think about the design now i'm sure
you've been seeing a lot of renders
floating around on the internet but for
some reason we just haven't been happy
with any of them with minor bits and
pieces seeming unrealistic like how thin
a lot of them have looked so we ended up
reaching out to renders by shailesh to
create some new renders of our own
matching up to what we think the design
will look like which is based off of the
design of the new macbook pros so as you
can see we think that it will also get a
nice curve on the top and bottom edge
but it's going to be quite a bit thinner
than the 14 inch pro with the same flat
design and in terms of the inside it's
got a notch to help the white bezel stay
as thin as possible around the same
13-inch display which will together help
the chassis size be even smaller and
more portable now the reason why we
think that it will have a notch is
because tie 98 believes it will and he
was actually the very first person ever
to mention that the macbook pros will
have a notch and he was right as for the
keyboard i expect it to also feature
white keys and before you say it's going
to be really dirty don't forget that the
magic keyboard on the imac comes with
white keys and i also think that the
keyboard will be off-white so it matches
the new macbook pro design as you can
see this one comes in a beautiful light
blue finish straight from the stand of
the blue 24 inch imac which will be very
consumer friendly and as for the ports i
expected to get the max a3 connector on
the left side a thunderbolt 4 port on
each side and a headphone jack on the
right and on the bottom you could see a
clean macbook air engraving and four
feet just like the pro models and if
you're interested in the simple and
clean blue macbook wallpaper i'll leave
a link to it in the video description
down below and while you're there go
ahead hit that subscribe button to help
us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers we would greatly appreciate
it now in terms of the release date i
think that mark's recent leak has
finally put the spring event release
rumor to rest he said that at least four
new macs powered by m2 chips are
launching later this year after apple
finishes releasing its final max with
the m1 pro and m1 max chips yep that is
right no m2 chip reveal until the last
of the m1 powered macs are released and
if you didn't know this already apple is
still selling both the intel based
high-end mac mini and the 27-inch imac
and both of those need to be switched
over to apple silicon before the m2
chips can be released so before i get
into when we can expect the m2 max to be
revealed we've got to cover those high
end m1 bass max first when we first saw
the leaked design of the m1 mac mini
from jon proster last year he said that
it could be coming as soon as the end of
2021
and even dylan dkt was confident that
the mac mini would launch alongside the
new 14 and 16 inch macbook pros but
unfortunately that didn't happen and his
reasoning for it was that apple wanted
the macbook pros to get all of the
attention to boost sales even though the
mac mini was likely ready at the time
and in mark german's report over the
weekend he confirmed that at least one
new mac will be revealed at the event
next month so with all of that said i
can almost 100 guarantee that it's gonna
be a mac mini for sure because the imac
side of things isn't looking too certain
ross young recently came out and said
that apple is unfortunately delaying the
release of their imac pro potentially as
late as august or september and this
actually came after a controversial
tweet from dylan dkt where he said that
there have been some concerns about the
shipping date of the imac pro and also
said that a september launch was the
worst case scenario so i think that it
totally makes sense for apple to reveal
the imac pro alongside the apple silicon
mac pro at their wwdc event in june and
this makes sense because both machines
are expected to come with the new
powerful m1 based chip either the 12
core chip that dylan leaked or the 20
core m1 max duo which literally means
two m1 max dies combined into one using
the high bandwidth fabric however we
asked ross young if there is a
possibility the apple could still
release a regular 27 inch imac in the
spring with just the same options of the
m1 pro and m1 max chips like we have in
the current macbook pros and he said he
wasn't sure about this because he was
only tracking imac pro models so with
that said we could still see a 2 000 27
inch mac model at the spring event
alongside the mac mini but it is not for
certain just yet now on top of all of
that mark also said something quite
controversial in his weekend report he
says that the technology to embed face
id into macbook displays doesn't exist
so if face id comes to the mac he thinks
that it will come on an imac or an
external monitor first and apple has
definitely been working on this but time
will tell if they launch it now if you
already didn't know 95 mac found code in
a mac os beta way back in 2020 showing
that they are working on it so in my
opinion i think it makes total sense for
this feature to be launched with the new
imac pro this year especially since we
just saw some new apple patents filed
concerning face id coming to the imac
but as far as the macbook side of things
even though we have that notch i don't
think we will see it until 2023 when
apple launches the m2 pro macbook pros
with a thinner face id module now the
last thing that i want to mention from
mark's weekend report is that the new
entry level m2 macbook pro will not be
getting a pro motion display which isn't
what we were expecting so what this
could mean is that it only comes with a
regular lcd display
but no i do not think that makes sense
because all of the leaks within the last
year pointed to the new redesigned
macbook air getting a mini led display
just like the current pro models that
are much more expensive so this means
that the new m2 entry-level macbook pro
that a lot of people have been waiting
for with the lower budget also needs
mini led so simply likely that the new
pro will have mini led but will lack pro
motion so if you want that sweet 120
hertz you will have to go for at least a
2 000 macbook pro which is a pretty
smart roof move from apple standpoint to
differentiate it and get people to spend
more money and now let's finish off with
when we will be getting the new m2 max
now i fully believe that they absolutely
must be revealed at an apple event after
all of the m1 base max are revealed
which i don't think will happen until
wwdc when apple reveals either the new
imac pro or the new mac pro or both so
with that said the only remaining option
would be the october event which is when
apple usually shows off their new mac
products and in my opinion there is a
chance that they could release all four
of them at once or at least within a
couple months of each other which sounds
a bit odd but i expect most of them to
be the simple chip spec updates like the
m2 mac mini and the 24 inch m2 imac the
entry level macbook pro will literally
just be a cheaper version of the current
m1 pro 14-ish macbook pro packed with an
m2 chip but lacking pro motion and
coming with less storage and ram at that
base price and remember the m2 chip will
be weaker than an m1 pro the redesigned
macbook air will be the only one that
will come with totally new features and
design changes like in these recent
renders with the white bezels and new
colors and all so with all that said let
me quickly run through the expected mac
lineup one more time we have the m1 pro
and max mac mini at the event next month
potentially alongside a matching new 27
imac then we have both the imac pro and
the mac pro at wwdc in june just to
finish out the two-year apple silicon
transition then we've got all of the m2
max at apple's october event with apple
potentially delaying one or two of them
by a month or two if they don't want to
release all four at once and there you
have it that is apple's updated 2022 mac
lineup which we can expect based on mark
german's recent bombshell report so
hopefully you enjoyed this video and if
you totally disagree with any of this
comment your thoughts down below we want
to hear your guys opinion if you enjoyed
it click that circle above to subscribe
to see more videos like this one and
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been max
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you